okay so here's a question do we forgive
student loan debt
that's gonna give the interest to start
off 100 percent yeah it's insane to me
that you could charge interest on loans
that the government is guaranteeing
isn't the entire point of interest like
all right i'm taking a risk by giving
you this money i don't know if i'm gonna
get it back so i should have something
to show for it
if the federal government is just giving
you the money or it's guaranteed that
you're gonna get it back the idea that
you'd be able to charge interest is
criminal
but they want they want you to be
permanently locked in place
yeah good little workers who can't leave
exactly no that's what it is that's why
it works out for them so think about
what's going on right now and how these
urban
millennials who went to college and have
missed this massive debt are facing
what's going on
their debts getting worse the deferments
the interest rates piling up they can't
find work
and then along comes a bernie sanders
yeah i'll give you
everything you've ever dreamed of i
totally understand yeah if
this happened 20 years ago if i was 20
years younger and i was 20 right now
i would be one of those people but you
know what it is bernie sanders
collectivist let's burn it all down and
undo all that it would've been crazy you
know you know you know why it's young
people
their net worth is eleven thousand
dollars right they don't they don't care
their net worth is negative probably
well actually uh millennial net worth
under 30 is negative
for yeah but it makes sense i mean part
of
the difficulty though is like if there
was and this is part of my problem with
the whole idea of like free education is
i think you end up with the exact same
problem that we have now it just
exacerbates itself because the whole
idea was again let's let poor people go
to college we're going to do that by
federally guaranteeing these student
loans
as soon as the consumer is removed from
the pricing structure and you just have
the government with these bottomless
pockets paying for everything the price
goes up
and then if it's based on loans people
end up with a lot more debt
i think what we need to focus on in this
country is improving the 12 years of
education that we do give to everybody
to ensure that they can be prepared for
the workforce or better yet just
do away with that i'm actually a big
advocate of homeschooling i think the
public school system is
completely broken i think we talked
about this last time but the idea that
people are not prepared for the
workforce after 12 years
of state-funded education and the
solution is to give them another four
to me that's crazy right high school
should be what college is
exactly yes completely agreed like teach
me how to start a business teach me how
to vote they didn't teach me
any of this stuff in high school teach
me how to write a check i didn't learn
how to write a check until
college i know what it is the aliens
domesticating
yeah you're right i think you're right
the aliens are conditioning us to be
good workers that's also true
the aliens are going to work for us
they're going to build more pyramids
that's the plan yeah they made us i'm
kidding yeah was that hilarious why
would they do that that would be such a
rude thing for aliens to do
instead of like giving us technology
they're going to like build some stone
triangles for it well what if they need
gold well what do they need it's true
did we talk about this gold is there
fuel
this is like this is like a really old
conspiracy theory that's been on the
internet for a long time
that they need gold to like replenish
their atmosphere or something i don't
know
did you you ever see those lights neil
degrasse tyson said that i think
you know well neil degrasse tyson said a
meteor is going to crash into earth
today on november 2nd
so you know here's hoping yeah i'm
waiting is there actually a meteor
coming close or something yeah yeah yeah
but i think it's it's really small i
think it's like six feet that's like
super tiny can i loop it back a little
bit because i know this is something
we've talked about a little bit
this is something that i'm very
compassionate with millennials on
because it makes a big difference to me
that millennials i would like them to be
happy and balanced and everything
and i think that part of the reason that
they're having so much problem is that
they have been sold a false bill of
goods i think they've been told that
they can go to college and get whatever
job they want and it's not true
nonsense things went to nothing you know
what i think one of the biggest problems
we have as a society
first i mean it starts young what do
american kids do from the ages of zero
to five years old watch
sesame street nothing
sit around watch tv i think it depends i
think it depends on the house
well for sure but on average like a lot
of kids are doing nothing especially in
cities well
i think there are a lot of parents here
who do just sit their kids in front of
the tv or the
or the table or whatever i would do i
was being uh
i was being homeschooled i was too
that's good too very very before or
before i yeah no that's true before i
went off to school my mom did teach me
to read oh yeah and i'm really bad at it
so now well so i'm saying
no that's the thing my mom taught me and
all of my siblings to read before we
ever went off to school and we were just
ahead of the other kids in our class
exactly because guess what no one's no
one's ever gonna be able to teach your
kid as well as you can
exactly i entered school knowing like
i'm in kindergarten i knew
multiplication and division and all this
math that was like grades above
everybody else
i had uh my vocabulary was several years
higher than the rest of the kids did you
skip
grades no i bet if you did you wouldn't
have dropped out you
would have fit because
i was 14 i went to high school and they
were like okay now open the book because
you're all morons and read the passages
you could have graduated high school by
the time you were fourteen i think you
could i probably could have just
skipped it yeah i probably could have
just because it would have been like a
ten-year-old in high school probably so
why
it's so stupid what we did in colorado
is that we had people go straight into
college
in high school you would go into high
school and come out with a college
degree
oh yeah yeah we have stuff like that
yeah like you would spend a certain
amount of time
like ap classes is kind of like that so
anyway look here's one of those here's
the point i'm getting too
not only was i homeschooled before i was
five years old i was like
as early as i could possibly communicate
my mom was teaching me my other
my siblings my family started a business
and i worked for the family business
when i was like nine years old
so i'm my mom my family started my mom
started a cafe
and so i was helping prepare drinks she
was showing me like management stuff
so i'm like 10 years old yeah i'm
learning from the real world i'm sitting
next to adults as they complain about
politics and i was i was immersed in all
of it
so so by the time i was 17 and they're
like it's time for college i was like
why yeah give me give me but so so what
happens now is
you've got 18 year old kids and they're
kids they're not adults they're not 18
year old men 18 year old women they're
18 year old kids
and they're like here sign this paper
where you can never you can never have
this debt bank you know cleared for the
bankruptcy or anything it's it's
attached to you forever
interest rates are psychotic and you
have no idea how this works because they
we've never taught you
science they don't teach compound
interest either yeah why not that's all
yeah that's that's true why not it makes
perfect sense no no it's true
so so crazy no there are workarounds but
we so we forgive the interest is that
what we're saying
i would say forgive the interest i would
your economy
well no you're right you got me i'm a
communist well no i just i think that
it's insane i think it's insane for
corporations to be able to profit off of
public money
yeah i mean as someone who believes in a
free market i think that's just like
antithetical to my principles in general
but
even so i believe in a free market but
i'm okay i believe there it's all right
to have some exceptions here and there
i'm not completely dogmatic on it
uh when it comes to student loan
forgiveness in general i'm not sure i
think
if we could work it out in a way where
my fear is if we did it we would just
we would we would push the problem off
further into the future and perpetuate
the same system of college becoming more
and more expensive and then people who
didn't go to college because they wanted
to save the money
are going to end up with the tax burden
of forgiving those debts
for people who did go to college uh and
so it's not
if it was just like we could wave away
all the debt i would say absolutely yes
and i certainly believe that that we
should um
prevent these these banks from being
able to collect any more interest on
them but
i don't i really uh didn't trump suspend
the interest rates during government
yeah
and i was i was saying that i was saying
that earlier in the year and then trump
didn't i'm like yeah
once once again how is the republicans
are doing the things that help the poor
in the situations you know what i mean
a couple of things one i fully agree
with you guys about homeschooling
from zero to five teaching kids
mathematics multiplication and division
do it from
because kids can learn math at the age
of three that's where we're at with
humanity is a genius
we have the internet you can do it
secondly do you agree with
defaulting on the debt to the federal
reserve i'm not sure
i don't know i don't know enough about
it i've heard a little bit and the
federal reserve has been a topic of
interest
for me for a while but when it comes to
defaulting on the loan to them
well then if yes then i'm in favor of it
no
i'm in let's go let's go let's do it
let's get crazy kids
yeah i'm not sure if we defaulted on the
interest only is what i'm talking about
what would that do
save our country like 20 trillion
dollars it would be super cool but what
is it
you could put that money into other
things yeah i guess
it's it's i i think it's a purposefully
complicated system so that no one really
has any idea and then everyone spends
their time arguing about one section of
it over here and then no one really
knows
but i can tell you the system as we have
it set up right now it's very difficult
for people to save unless you go into a
market or make some kind of investment
account or whatever yeah but now that
interest rates are in the gutter because
of kovid
it's like what do you do you just gotta
spend money and build something
so ultimately the best thing you can do
start a business
make money for yourself the problem is
going back to the same before we have a
bunch of young people
they spend listen let me ask you a
question what were you doing when you
were 13 years old when i was 13 years
old i was actually starting to teach
myself to animate and i was also buying
broken computers and fixing them so i
could resell them and now here you are
you have a show you animate you've got a
you know a couple hundred
how many subscribers you have 460
dollars very successful youtube channel
thank you
very blessed so i i when i was uh 13 i
was playing music i was skateboarding i
was doing flash animation i was doing
flashlights
video games i was working all the stuff
and uh
you know generally hanging out with
people and learning how the computers
worked and all this stuff
a bunch of other people i know who ended
up going to college getting a degree
they didn't need
because they didn't know what they were
doing with massive debt i said what were
you doing when you were 13 they were
like nothing riding bikes
that's it they would go out and play
with their friends they would go to
school and do the bare minimum
and so we have we have young people who
are being raised by a system that does
not teach them to do
anything and now we have a generation of
millennials who can't do anything
and their net worth is really low and
they're in massive debt and they can't
find jobs then covet hits now
now you got communism yeah the only way
out is if i don't got stuff
and you do i get your stuff yeah huh
yeah i used to tell my parents they were
like what do you want to do
and i said i want to be an actor and
then they said well then you should
start acting
i want to be a communist and take people
start acting like it yeah yeah exactly
i auditioned for a play when i was 16. i
was a little later to the table i was 16
when i started
so good before that i was working at a
job playing magic cards but i had my own
job since i was 12
yeah [ __ ] dogs i remember in high
school working this really really lame
job i had is a friend of ours
um i don't want to say the name of the
company because they will get hashtag
canceled for hiring me in high school
but it was just it was literally like an
ushering slash security business where
you
you would just stand there for between
like a 12 and 16 hour shift
and just tell people no like either let
me see your ticket or no you can't use
that door
and then people would like yell at you
for things that were clearly not your
fault which happens to low-level workers
constantly
like people this is the thing man people
will go to mcdonald's
and think that the kid behind the
counter is stupid but like i guarantee
you he thinks you're a [ __ ] because he
gets asked
such dumb questions by all the customers
all day you know
dude we were just uh i was just at a
fast food place thing
i was at a fat festive place it was like
it was a nathan's hot dogs the guy was
saying yeah
jerk some guy walked up and he started
yelling at these like
these the workers there like horrible
he's like look at this and he opens the
hot dog thing
and they were just like well done i
don't say they were burned he was like
look at those hot dogs and look at this
why would you give me this
and then she's like i don't know it's
like because i don't like you yeah i did
it it was personal
but the crazy thing is i'm like dude if
you went up and you were like hey i'm
sorry to bug you but like these these
hot dogs kind of suck can i get the good
ones
she might be like i don't care it's not
my money like you got it you got to be
mean not only that like she might hook
it up she might be like dude i'm not the
manager here let me give you the best
ones possible i'm sorry about that
it doesn't like why be mean to people i
don't know what people feel good or
something well people just have a
tendency of taking their anger out on
whoever they can get away with taking
their anger out on her she's not
necessarily supposed
to it's horrible though i agree so
here's the other thing
so there there was an article recently
uh it's
recently it's like the other day it's in
the atlantic saying that voting for joe
biden is
the right thing to do if you are worried
about the woke left or the liberal left
what a great plan yeah that's like
blackmail like don't if you're afraid of
getting your throat cut vote for the guy
that's threatening you
yeah wait hold on hold on that's what
they say
they're like if someone tries taking
your stuff just give it to them just
give up
that's what they tell you to do that's
um so so isn't that letting the
terrorists win isn't that like the whole
thing we've talked about for 20 years
so here's the terrorist win they're
saying that
donald trump fans the flames of the
liberal left or whatever and i'm like
joe biden's negotiating with them i'd
rather have a guy fighting against them
but anyway i digress
so uh there's another article by helen
pluckrose that made a similar argument
and i don't want to put words in her
mouth
but basically when i responded with you
know why would i vote for the guy
like it would just justify their tactics
the violence and the extremism
and her response was i wouldn't vote for
antifa either i i felt like i'm not
trying to put words in her mouth but to
me
that she was arguing joe biden is not
antifa okay well of course joe biden
isn't
of course joe biden is not a socialist
he's just the guy on bent knee begging
them for their votes because he doesn't
have a coalition to defeat donald trump
yeah so he's already done the bernie
sanders pact he's already negotiating
with him he won't call them out but more
importantly
in new york just the other day a bunch
of people were throwing eggs and rocks
at trump supporters in their cars and
apparently i think it was a woman
ran up to an suv and pepper sprayed
everyone including the children
that's not antifa oh okay listen it was
just
some brooklyn leftist these are the
people saying drumpf is bad
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna give them
what they want they pepper sprayed kids
because a guy had a trump flag
so i'm not voting for this guy you know
what i mean remember when john oliver
said orange man bad and then pepper
sprayed his audience
i don't know what he did remember that i
should be less dry
yeah i was just thinking of like a very
i was thinking of like a very
establishment guy but so here's here's
where i bring this up you get all these
young people
who have been pushed into this grinder
they have massive debt they can't pay it
off the interest is piling up covet
happens
and now they go insane and so i'm in
favor of forgiving that interest
but these people have snapped now
they're throwing eggs at people pepper
spraying kids
not all of them not every single one but
how how often do you hear about these
stories
where a trump supporter gets attacked
there's there's like several thousand
stories like this
over the past four years where they're
getting harassed attacked
threatened in the street these people
have snapped and what it is
many of them need a symbol of what they
hate
to attack damage right that's right why
did why did
why did the far left just throw a brick
through the starbucks window right
because starbucks is a massive
corporation that symbolizes their
their hatred and their anger and you
oppress me so they throw a brick to the
window it does nothing
it does nothing to help their cause it
hurts their cause but it feels good
now people have replaced that symbol of
the big corporations with
trump so now they see a trump supporter
and they're like
you and they're taking all of that anger
and they're directing it towards random
people who are waving flags
that's yeah no i totally get where
you're coming from and i'm sympathetic
to
a lot of the struggles that people
discuss younger people going through
right now
i've said this in the past i mean i'm
unbelievably blessed i came from a
two-parent home
uh i was really raised with like really
solid catholic values i was just set up
in
a lot of the really the best possible
ways to be set up so
i absolutely don't look down on anybody
because their circumstances are harder i
just think that the solutions being
proposed by the left are horrible
and i think they're taking advantage of
people who are going through extremely
difficult times
uh and i would also say this there was a
time when like
instead of telling people to check their
privilege we'd tell them like count
their blessings
because we wanted people to be grateful
instead of feeling guilty
and that's more or less where i'm like
yeah i got a lot of great things out of
life i've been tremendously blessed
i don't feel guilty about that i feel
grateful for that i thank god every day
for the life that i've gotten because
i've gotten so much that i
don't deserve but to say that the
solution to that is to like bend over
and have this white guilt and tell
people
take whatever you want from me um
implement whatever system makes you
happier that you think in the moment
might be best for this country despite
all the evidence saying it will never
work is is completely insane but that's
exactly what they want
that's exactly why they want people to
feel guilt this is the interesting thing
about wealth inequality arguments and
andrew yang saying like abolish poverty
or whatever i don't know
exactly what his hat said but something
to that effect because
we are actively abolishing poverty
capitalism is doing that like the curve
is like going way down like poor people
in this country are poor but many of
them have air conditioning well
that's the thing right so about 99 of
the world population subsists off of
less than thirty thousand dollars per
year or makes less than thirty thousand
dollars per year so if you make 30 grand
a year or more you are in the top one
percent of the global
totally yeah um and also global poverty
has been decreasing for decades
unfortunately until these lockdowns
which shut down our production chain
now there are more people for the first
time in decades or i believe two decades
there are more people at risk for
starvation this year
than there were last year and it's it's
a massive swarth
so yeah things things are going in the
opposite direction but that also shows
you
and that can help inform us on uh
people making claims like oh how could
you put economics above human life
you know anytime you don't know what
economics means exactly they don't know
what economics means
um they think it's just some abstraction
that you know wall street i think it
means you make it
believing it yes exactly but all
economics is about is like promoting
human well-being and flourishing
and when you shut down the entire
economy guess what happens people starve
to death and it's hilarious because
the left was arguing for so long that if
you even want to cut a penny of welfare
spending
then poor people are just going to die
because when people don't have money
they don't have access to resources and
when they don't have access to resources
they die but but we can shut down the
entire global economy for three months
and no one's gonna die because of that
we're actually gonna save lives so
that's insane
here's the interesting thing about
wealth inequality i always hear they're
like
jeff bezos is worth a hundred and
whatever billion dollars and there are
people sleeping in the streets that's a
huge problem for our country
and those are two completely separate
things that have are completely
unrelated
if you took away jeff bezos's money
you're not going to get people not
living on the streets
these people fundamentally don't
understand how wealth works or how
homelessness works no
they just think i i love it when people
say things like
think about how many empty homes we have
we could put homeless people in them
and it's like you you can't just do that
it that
some any people who say that clearly
i've never owned a home understanding
how much work goes in what happens if
you put a homeless guy in a house
and then the plumbing breaks or the
house burns down because of faulty
wiring and the dude dies
well what happens to the real estate
market and all the people who actually
have a mortgage in a home that they
spend all this money on what happens
like their property value or their home
and then what happens to people who make
their business
or make their money renting i mean you
would actually have to you would have to
radically restructure the entire economy
to do something like that it's not just
a question of putting homeless people in
homes
that said there are solutions like there
are ways on the table and things that we
can discuss to get homeless people
housing 100
that's not the issue though yeah yeah no
i agree the issue is homelessness is
driven
mostly by mental health exactly so for
these people to come out and say
people shouldn't be homeless we should
tax the wealthy it's not right it's like
those are two entirely different
universes
you know one of my favorite sayings is
from people
feed the homeless yeah have you heard
that yeah we want to go out and feed the
homeless i'm like bro
why they're they're not foodless yeah
they're homeless
yeah there's a difference just because
they don't live anywhere doesn't mean
they're hungry
you want to feed the hungry that's what
you want to do but there's like these
weird things
and these people they have good
intentions and i respect it but i
actually worked as a director at a
homeless shelter actually worked for
many nonprofits
and the problem is mental health and
choices people make
no amount of money because some of some
of the shelters were empty
why homeless people didn't want to be in
them they they wanted
to do drugs well and a lot of the a lot
of well maybe the thing a lot of part of
it a lot of shelters are empty now
because you talk to homeless people they
will tell you like i can't get anywhere
to stay right now because the shelters
in my city are closed down because of
cover 19.
another thing that's interesting is um
and i i mean it's of course it's good to
feed homeless people i firmly believe
that
um but a lot of it is like again this
problem of them not having housing
as opposed to not having food though
again i believe we should feed them
that said so many homeless people have
said to me um don't mess with drugs
don't mess with alcohol
which is an interesting thing to say
like they'll they'll start sort of
explaining some of the things that
ruin their lives and encouraging you not
to do it now i'm not saying because they
ruin their lives in these ways that we
just let them hang there absolutely not
but it's a horrible tragedy and
a big part of it was the
deinstitutionalization movement that we
had in the 1970s
so even um without even adjusting for
changes in our population size
there are less people in mental health
facilities today
than there were before the 70s which is
completely insane
uh and i think that's part of why we're
seeing more massacres i think it's part
of
i mean mental illness has become a much
more serious issue in this country
because we don't take it as seriously as
we used to
yes and i think that's also why
homelessness is such a problem because
there are people who
should be in the hospital they should be
in a mental health facility but they're
not they're out on the streets instead
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you